dr. Don limbs job is emergency medicine
she's on the front line treating
patients with kovat 19 but there's
another layer to what she does after a
shift or on her days off she picks up
her camera and turns it on her
colleagues capturing what few of us see
the care the precision and the
unpredictability of what it takes to
save lives dr. Lim wants to create a
permanent record of how this pandemic
plays out she's shared her photographs
with us my name is dr. Don Lim I'm an
emergency physician at the University
Health Network which is Toronto General
Hospital and Toronto Western Hospital
that is porn half one was five and my
daughter is 16 months now so every time
I say goodbye I close the door and my
son's always waiting for me with my
daughter and my husband the bangs on the
window and he says goodbye it makes a
little heart with his index finger and
his thumb and he can't he tries to shout
I love you mom and goodbye and but
that's what he means when he says that
to make sure that I'm brave and as soon
as I get back everything comes off and
goes straight into the wash and I don't
I don't hug my kids I don't say even
hello to them until I've had a really
long shower when the fear of the
pandemic and the unknown started that's
when we started actually talking to our
colleagues who had gone through SARS and
what was that like and one of them told
me that it was very hard for her team
because afterwards when you know the
last patient was cured and they lifted
the restrictions it wasn't something
that they talked about and so I felt
that I felt like this story couldn't be
forgotten the same way that stars was
forgotten because we wanted to make sure
that each person with Cova door
suspected kovat had the minimal exposure
to team members the hospital actually
created a team called the ko Delta team
which is an intubation team staffed by
and anesthesia assistant a nurse and a
staff Aneesa test they're checking their
equipment they're making sure they have
all their medications and they're making
sure that they're completely covered and
safe for the intubation I felt at the
very beginning I thought maybe it was a
crazy idea to try to document the
pandemic because I thought maybe people
wouldn't be receptive when I brought up
this idea that people were very
supportive of it and they knew that if
we didn't talk about it then the story
would be forgotten just like SARS the
patient is about to be intubated it's
very challenging so they decompensate
very quickly so you pretty much have one
shot to get the intubation before they
go get into trouble and the person who's
doing the intubation really wants to
minimize any type of procedure that will
increase aerosolization so it's a first
shot one shot do it right
usually we are used to dealing with
patients who are very sick that's not
new but patients with kovat they they
look well until they don't look well and
that's been very scary visitors aren't
allowed and so when we do have patients
who died not being able to close that
circle and have the family nearby has
been really tough for the team so she's
got the baby monitor in her hand and
she's looking very carefully to see what
the team needs so if you imagine the
face shields and the face mask it's very
hard to hear people and you've also got
the wall of clothes only a few can stay
inside and everyone's on the outside and
everyone's waiting to see what's going
to happen and waiting to make sure that
the team inside has everything that they
need he and his team are responsible for
making sure that the room is
meticulously cleaned after each patient
and you see that he's he's doing a lot
of work to do to keep a keep to keep the
whole team safe we really appreciate
them a lot of the pictures of people's
eyes are so focused and you see such a
concentration
but I do see a strain on people people's
faces and I do see the uncertainty in
their eyes because we're there to help
them and at the same time we feel very
vulnerable ourselves and that's very
hard to talk about I think it's very
common for healthcare providers to not
feel that they necessarily can ask for
help or if they do need help there's a
stigma associated with that sometimes
and this is the the pause that our teams
do at the time of death to pay respects
to the patient that pre kovat it it was
quite common to have the family members
nearby but this patient had only the
medical team to say goodbye so you know
looking at this I think this was a very
special moment for this team as well
because they they knew that what they
had they tried to do everything they
could and still they lost the patient so
it's the time of death so a very moving
photo for the team as well
storytelling for me is the most powerful
tool that we have for connection and
healing but I hope that by doing this
photo essay people remember that feeling
that they had when we came together as a
team that's what I hope that they take
away from it because I think that's the
power of art it gives us permission to
pause and reflect
[Music]